>> THAT’S A SHIFT.
THANKS FOR THAT.
REALLY INTERESTING STORY.
KATIE PAVLICH EDITOR OF TOWN
HALL.COM.
YOU KNOW THE STORY WELL AND
PROBABLY IN AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY THEY’RE HAVING SIMILAR
DEBATES.
HOW DO YOU SEE THIS ONE?
>> THEY ARE HAVING SOME MORE
DEBATES.
A CULMINATION OF PARENTS OVER
THE PAST YEAR, YEAR AND A HALF
REALLY BEING IGNORED ON THE
NATIONAL AND LOCAL LEVEL.
FIGHTING TEACHERS UNIONS TO GET
THEIR KIDS BACK IN SCHOOL AND
NOW THEY ARE LOOKING AT THESE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS REQUIRING
LITTLE KIDS TO WEAR MASKS ALL
DAY LONG DESPITE THE SCIENCE
SHOWING THAT MIGHT NOT BE
NECESSARY.
THERE IS AN INTERESTING STUDY
OUT OF BROWN UNIVERSITY SHOWING
THAT ACTUALLY MASK MANDATES IN
SCHOOLS K-12 SCHOOLS DON’T
NECESSARILY STOP THE SPREAD OF
THIS DISEASE AND SO THE
REQUIRING KIDS TO DO THIS AND
YESTERDAY YOU HAD A NURSE ON
THE CHANNEL SAYING LOOK, SHE
SEES THESE KIDS, SHE IS IN NEW
JERSEY.
THERE ARE INJURIES BEING
INFLICTED ON THESE KIDS FROM
WEARING MASKS FOR EIGHT HOURS A
DAY.
THEY GET BLISTERS ON THEIR
MOUTH, WEARING DIRTY MASKS, NOT
WEARING THEM PROPERLY AND
SWITCHED OUT THE RIGHT WAY.
THERE ARE OTHER CONSEQUENCES
FOR THIS.
TO HAVE THE SCHOOL BOARD ALLOW
POLITICIANS TO TAKE THE TIME
AWAY FROM THE PARENTS WHO HAVE
BEEN PAYING FOR ALL OF THIS ON
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT LEVELS IS
PRETTY EGREGIOUS BEHAVIOR.
>> Dana: DR. GOTLIEB HAD THIS
TO SAY.
>> I CAN THINK WE CAN DO IT NOW.
I THINK WE SHOULD START LIFTING
THESE RESTRICTIONS AS
AGGRESSIVELY WE PUT THEM N. WE
HAVE TO PRESERVE THE
CREDIBILITY OF PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS TO REIMPLEMENT THEM
IF WE START SEEING OUTBREAKS.
THE ONLY WAY TO HAVE PUBLIC
CREDIBILITY YOU NEED TO RELAX
THESE WHEN THE SITUATION
IMPROVES.
>> Dana: HE WAS LIKE EVERYONE
NEEDS TO TAKE IT SERIOUSLY AND
NOW SAYING WE’RE AT A POINT
WHEN WE CAN DO THIS DO YOU
THINK PEOPLE MIGHT LISTEN?
>> I THINK PEOPLE ARE LISTENING.
I’M NOT SURE IF THE PEOPLE AT
THE CDC ARE LISTENING AND DR.
FAUCI WITH THE NEW CDC
GUIDELINES THEY PUT OUT FOR
KIDS TO BE MASKED AT SUMMER
CAMP OUTSIDE AND DOING ALL
THESE THINGS THAT ARE CONTRARY
TO WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THE DATA
OF HOW THIS DISEASE SPREADS
OUTSIDE AND AMONG YOUNGER
CHILDREN.
AND SO I THINK YOU WILL SEE
MORE FRUSTRATION FROM PARENTS.
MORE FRUSTRATION FROM REGULAR
ADULTS SAYING I GOT VACCINATED
OR MAYBE I DIDN’T GET
VACCINATED BUT WE KNOW THE
DISEASE IS GOING AWAY AND I
SHOULDN’T BE SHAMED OR FORCED
TO CONTINUE ACTING LIKE WE’RE
IN THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC
LAST SUMMER WHEN THINGS HAVE
CHANGED ON THE GROUND.
SO THAT INCENTIVE IS CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE GIVEN
BUT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
HASN’T SHOWN ANY WILLINGNESS TO
CHANGE THINGS EITHER.
SO THE PRESIDENT WEARING A MASK
OUTSIDE.
>> Bill: THAT’S RIGHT.
WE SAW HIM IN PLAINS, GEORGIA
WITH THE CARTERS, RIGHT?
THEY WERE INSIDE WITH THEM
WITHOUT A MASK, TOOK A PICTURE.
CAME OUTSIDE AND WEARING MASKS.
KAMALA HARRIS BOTH WEARING
MASKS AND SHE KISSED HER
HUSBAND BEFORE THEY GET ON THE
PLANE.
CONFUSING SIGNALS DOESN’T
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO GET THE
VACCINE.
HOW WILL THEIR LIFE CHANGE?
>> THAT’S A KEY POINT.
>> Bill: END THE MASK MANDATE
IS THE CASE HE MAKES.
IT IS YOUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
PROTECT YOURSELF BY GETTING
YOUR SHOTS.
HE CONCLUDES THE MESSAGE TO
EVERYONE VACCINES WORK AND IT’S
TIME TO GET BACK TO NORMAL.
HIS PLEA IS TO END THE MANDATE
ON MEMORIAL FEBRUARY, FEBRUARY
28th.
I DON’T KNOW IF THAT’S
SOMETHING PRESIDENT BIDEN WOULD
DO.
INTERESTING THOUGHT IN ORDER TO
GET ENCOURAGEMENT OUT THERE.
>> THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
GOVERNMENTS AND LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CONTINUE TO MAKE THIS
ARGUMENT THAT THESE
RESTRICTIONS ARE NECESSARY
BECAUSE IT GIVES THEM AN
ARGUMENT ON THE OTHER SAID TO
SAY WHAT THEY NEED TO DO IN
ORDER TO FIX THE PROBLEM.
WHETHER IT’S MORE GOVERNMENT
SPENDING OR ESPECIALLY AMONG
THE TEACHERS UNIONS THEY WANT
MORE MONEY TO MAKE THEIR
SCHOOLS SAFER AS THEY TRY TO
ARGUE.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN VERY PATIENT.
THEY HAVE BEEN VERY COMPLIANT
WHEN IT COMES TO TRYING TO GET
THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC IN THE
RIGHT WAY POSSIBLE AND THEY
HAVE SEEN A NUMBER OF MIXED
SIGNALS FROM PEOPLE LIKE DR.
FAUCI, FROM THE WHITE HOUSE,
FROM GUIDELINES THAT WERE GIVEN
LAST SUMMER HOW TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THIS.
WHEN DR. GOTLIEB SAYS THIS IS
ABOUT CREDIBILITY FOR HEALTH
OFFICIALS NOW, IT IS.
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE SAYING I’VE
DONE EVERYTHING I’M SUPPOSED TO
DO AND YET I STILL CAN’T GO
BACK TO ACTING LIKE I’M IN MY
NORMAL LIFE AGAIN DESPITE DOING
EVERYTHING I’M TOLD.
THAT IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
BODES WELL FOR THE FUTURE IF
THERE WERE ANOTHER HEALTH
CRISIS IN TERMS OF PEOPLE
LISTENING TO THOSE GUIDELINES
SINCE THEY’VE BEEN CHANGED SO
OFTEN.
>> Bill: VERY INTERESTING TO
HEAR FROM THOSE PARENTS
FIGHTING FOR THEIR KIDS.